ah no está estudiando de los patrones
migratorios de las golondrinas ha estado
siguiendo los movimientos de una bandada
europea y una bandada africana la banda
europea se está moviendo hacia el norte
con una velocidad rapidez y dirección am
de esta que tenemos aquí justo este
vector que tenemos aquí es decir el
vector 15 velocidad de la bandada
europea ok
está azul mientras que la banda africana
se está moviendo hacia el sur con una
velocidad la velocidad de la bandada
africana está que tenemos de color
morado es el vector
2 - 7 y es este vector que tenemos aquí
los valores de arriba están dados en
kilómetros por día
ok cuanto más rápido se está moviendo
las golondrinas africanas con respecto a
las europeas y bueno se nota que las
golondrinas africanas se están moviendo
más rápido que las golondrinas europeas
pero hay que saber cuanto más rápido se
está moviendo
las africanas que las europeas y bueno
el resultado nos lo piden en kilómetros
por día redondea a décimas ahora vamos a
empezar con esta primera pregunta y
después nos pasamos a esta segunda
pregunta cuanto más rápido se están
moviendo las golondrinas africanas con
respecto a las europeas
bueno pues sería muy bueno saber cuál es
la magnitud de este rector cuál es la
magnitud de este vector y comparar ambas
magnitudes para ver por cuántos le gana
esta magnitud a esta de aquí y para eso
vamos a pensar un poco cuánto vale cada
uno de estos dos vectores es decir qué
información me están dando por ejemplo
aquí
en este vector este efector en este de
color azul me están diciendo que es el
vector 15 eso quiere decir que por cada
uno que nosotros nos movamos de manera
horizontal nos vamos a mover 5 hacia
arriba de manera vertical dicho de otra
manera am y déjame tomar este color si
este primero voy a tomar este color si
este es mi origen ok
00 entonces esto quiere decir que mi
componente horizontal
es moverme uno hacia la derecha es decir
que este vector lo podríamos ver como el
vector y con el vector unitario y ok y
después me voy a mover cinco unidades
hacia arriba es decir hasta llegar a
este punto de aquí y bueno si te das
cuenta esta sería mi otra componente en
el componente vertical y esta componente
vertical es lo mismo que cinco veces el
vector unitario j ok de lujo dicho de
otra manera a este vector de subíndice m
lo podemos ver como el vector y más
cinco veces el doctor j
de hecho con eso llegamos el punto 15
que es este punto de aquí este punto de
aquí es el punto 1,5 1,5 ahora cómo
podemos obtener la magnitud de este
vector de azul que nosotros queremos
bueno pues es muy fácil si ya sabemos la
longitud de este vector y la longitud de
este vector
simple y sencillamente recordar un
teorema de pitágoras recordar un teorema
de pitágoras porque este es un triángulo
rectángulo y por lo tanto la magnitud de
esta velocidad subíndice m
y déjame ponerlo así así aquí quiero
calcular la magnitud de esta velocidad
su índice bueno pues esto lo podemos
calcular como la raíz cuadrada la raíz
cuadrada de esta magnitud elevada al
cuadrado más esta magnitud elevado al
cuadrado es decir 1 elevado al cuadrado
1 elevado al cuadrado lo cual es uno más
a esto le voy a sumar 5 elevado al
cuadrado lo cual es 25 dicho de otra
manera la longitud o la magnitud de este
vector b subíndice m es exactamente lo
mismo que la raíz de 26 ok y bueno la
raíz de 26 y nosotros la calculamos
aproximadamente con nuestra calculadora
déjeme traer por acá a mi calculadora la
tengo justo por acá entonces sacamos la
raíz de 20
esto es aproximadamente 5.1 5.1
redondeado a décimas entonces esto es
aproximadamente 5.1 de lujo
ahora vamos a fijarnos cuál es la
magnitud de este subíndice am y para eso
vamos a hacer algo muy parecido si te
das cuenta podemos fijar aquí el origen
y entonces decir que nosotros nos vamos
a mover y lo tenemos justo por acá este
de aquí nosotros nos podemos fijar en
estas coordenadas y darnos cuenta que
tenemos que movernos dos en la dirección
horizontal es decir me voy a mover dos
para acá
esta va a ser mi componente horizontal
esta de aquí ok que tiene por cierto una
magnitud de 2 o lo podemos ver como el
vector 2
y bueno también vamos a bajar 7 unidades
es decir nuestra componente vertical es
esta de aquí de aquí hasta acá son siete
unidades vamos a bajar siete unidades y
bueno también podemos decir que este es
el vector
7 j menos 7 j ok de lujo y es negativo
porque estamos yendo hacia abajo ahora
date cuenta otra vez que encontramos
aquí un triángulo rectángulo con este
color lo voy a poner y por lo tanto
también podemos calcular de una manera
sencilla cuánto vale la magnitud de este
vector ve subir sea y déjame ponerlo
aquí la magnitud la magnitud de este
vector ve subíndice am esto es
exactamente lo mismo que la raíz
cuadrada de la magnitud de la primera
componente elevada al cuadrado es decir
2 por 24 ya esto hay que sumarle a esto
hay que sumarle a la magnitud de esta
componente elevada al cuadrado pero la
magnitud de esta componente son 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 unidades
por lo tanto 7 es la magnitud de este
vector que voy a elevar al cuadrado 10
humedad 49-49 ok y bueno entonces para
encontrar justo la magnitud que nosotros
queremos
a la magnitud de este pez humilde sea
esto es exactamente lo mismo que la raíz
de 49 4 lo cual es 53 y bueno esto es
aproximadamente aproximadamente voy a
sacar otra vez la calculadora por acá y
tengo por aquí mi calculadora y ahora sí
voy a calcular la raíz de 53 ok es 7.28
redondeado decimales 7.3 ok entonces
esto es aproximadamente a 7.3 7.3 ok
perfecto ya solamente nos falta saber
cuál es la diferencia de estos dos para
saber cuanto más rápido se están
moviendo las golondrinas africanas con
respecto a las europeas y bueno vamos a
escribirlo aquí si yo me tomo entonces a
aquí lo voy a poner con este color la
diferencia de la magnitud de esta
velocidad de subíndice am ok a esto le
voy a restar
voy a restar a esta de aquí le voy a
restar la magnitud de esta velocidad
subíndice ok esto es exactamente igual
esto es exactamente igual que a 7.3
menos 5.1 lo cual es 2.2 eso es muy
fácil de calcular 2.2 y lo voy a
escribir aquí 2.2 aproximadamente
kilómetros por día es cuanto más rápido
se están moviendo las golondrinas
africanas con respecto a las golondrinas
europeas de liu ya tenemos la primera
respuesta ahora hay que pensar en la
segunda pregunta y bueno mi segunda
pregunta dice qué tan rápido crece la
distancia entre las bandadas y bueno
para resolver esta pregunta qué te
parece si estos dos vectores los ponemos
en un mismo plano cartesiano así que
déjame bajar un poco para acá a esta
pantalla y vamos a pensar en un plano
cartesiano que voy a dibujar justo aquí
así que voy a hacer dos líneas este va a
ser mi eje de las equis y este por acá
va a ser
desde las 10 vamos a poner que estos son
mis ejes este es mi eje x ok mientras
que este es mi hijo james ok y bueno mi
primer vector es el 1,5 entonces am
siguió camino 1 para acá y nuevos 5 para
arriba 1 2 3 4 5 ok entonces por aquí
aquí va a estar mi cabeza de este vector
y entonces mi vector se vería más o
menos sin punto este con este y date
cuenta que este es mi primer vector ok
de lujo ahora fijémonos en el segundo mi
segundo vector era el 2,7 así que
déjenme contar dos para acá
contemos 1 2 y 7 para abajo 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 es decir que por aquí va a estar la
cabeza del vector ok y déjame dibujarlo
este de aquí va a ser mi vector
justo este de kim de lujo y déjame
dibujar una pequeña flecha ahora si te
das cuenta estas bolas las golondrinas
que van emigrando en europa
hacia esta dirección mientras que estas
golondrinas las golondrinas que están en
áfrica van volando hacia esta dirección
si te das cuenta las dos se van alejando
por lo tanto lo que me gustaría saber es
cuánto vale este a y déjame ponerlo con
otro color este vector es decir cuál es
la magnitud de este vector para ver cómo
se están alejando las dos bandadas date
cuenta que esta es la distancia a la que
se van alejando las dos bandadas y bueno
lo que se me ocurre hacer para resolver
esta pregunta es pensar en la magnitud
de este vector realmente si me tomo este
vector hacia arriba o hacia abajo es lo
mismo así que me lo voy a tomar hacia
arriba porque lo que me importa es la
magnitud de este vector ok
en ese sitio lo que yo saber es cuál es
la magnitud de este vector pero este
vector es la diferencia estos dos
vectores el vector b subíndice m ya esto
le voy a quitar el otro vector el vector
b subíndice a b sub índice a y yo lo que
quiero saber es justo
cuánto vale esta magnitud date cuenta
que si a éste
el subíndice am le sumamos este vector b
vean llegamos a este vector b subíndice
y para obtener esta magnitud
primero voy a ver cuánto vale y déjame
ponerlo con este color
bm subíndice menos b subíndice a b
subíndice a y bueno esto es exactamente
lo mismo pero ya nos tenemos
descompuestos en sus componentes
horizontales y verticales de subíndice
es lo mismo que tomarme al vector
unitario y ok al vector unitario y y
sumarle 5 veces el vector unitario jota
y sumarle 5 veces el vector unitario
jota y este vector de subíndice a
también lo podemos ver a a esto le voy a
quitar déjame ponerlo con este color le
voy a quitar le voy a cambiar el signo a
este vector b subíndice amp que es dos
veces el vector unitario y ok pero con
este signo menos me va a quedar menos
dos veces el vector de unitario y ya
esto le tengo que sumar
siete veces el vector unitario j pero
con este menos me va a dar más más ok 7
p ese es el vector unitario jota y bueno
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
el vector unitario y menos dos veces
vector interior y eso es lo mismo que
menos el vector unitario y ya esto le
tenemos que sumar a 12 veces el vector
unitario jota más 12 veces el vector
unitario jota ok de lujo y bueno por lo
tanto ya tengo las componentes
rectangulares de este vector diferencia
y bueno por lo tanto para calcular la
magnitud y déjame ponerlo aquí para
calcular la magnitud de esto que tenemos
aquí lo voy a copiar lo voy a pegar ok
lo voy a poner justo aquí bueno pues lo
único que hay que hacer es tomarme la
raíz cuadrada ok esto va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de la magnitud de cada
una de estas dos componentes elevadas al
cuadrado
ok entonces menos 1 al cuadrado va a ser
1 ya esto le voy a sumar 12 al cuadrado
lo cual es 100
44 más 144 ok de lujo y esto va a ser
exactamente igual ok que la raíz
cuadrada de 145 ok y bueno esto va a ser
igual saquemos la calculadora por acá me
voy a traer a mi calculadora y quiero
sacar la raíz de 145 sus raíces 12 punto
y si lo redondeamos a décimas es 12 este
baja y no van a quedar dos entonces am
lo voy a poner si esto es
aproximadamente aproximadamente 2 y
bueno es justo lo que voy a poner aquí
qué tan rápido crece la distancia entre
las bandadas bueno pues se alejan a 12
kilómetros por día así que de lujo ya
acabamos nos vemos en el siguiente